[Musik]
was hast du denn da du stehst nur fürs
licht da schafft diesem video tiere der
film traumfabrik führt uns in der ddr im
jahr 1961 näher hin in ein filmstudio
der ddr in die defa studios in potsdam
babelsberg gehversuche staatliche studie
unter ddr das heißt es dort wurden die
filme gemacht in denen sich der
sozialistische deutsche staat wieder
erkennen wollte also dies gab es auch
dort so etwas wie eine schale produktion
mit der historischen tv hat aber nicht
viel zu tun was uns rechtlich frei in
den ersten szenen von traumfabrik zeigt
den er führt uns in ein studio bei dem
wir hier am hollywood denken könnten und
auch da im speziellen an ein hollywood
in dem es so aussieht als würden fünf
oder sechs monumentalfilm ihr
gleichzeitig gedreht werden das heißt es
laufen oder lackieren
kostüme art und weise daran explodierte
etwas und in diese überwältigen könnte
man sagen situation in diese szenerie in
der ständig etwas verkühlt es passiert
kommt ein junger mann namens e mail
er wird erhält das bild werden da kommt
direkt von der infra also vom
militärdienst ddr und er versucht nun
etwas zu finden für sein junges leben
und für einen namen mit seinen
abenteuergeist und auch mit seinem guten
aussehen ist vielleicht ein filmstudio
genau die richtige umgebung dazu kommt
als vorteil dass sein bruder bereits
dort arbeitet das heißt er hat auch ein
gewisses andré allerdings sind seine
ersten auftritte oder seine ersten
versuche dort für sich einen platz zu
schaffen vor allem durch peinlichkeiten
geprägt er tritt zuerst als tollpatsch
auf aber das passt ihm auch zu der idee
von traumfabrik der zu beginn vor allem
eine eine komödie zu sein versuchen im
weiteren verlauf geht es dann aber dann
doch vor allem um eine dramatische
geschichte traumfabrik will nicht viel
weniger sein als eine der ganz großen
liebesgeschichten des kinos berlin ist
im ausnahmezustand
die haben die ost west grenze zu gemacht
außerdem sind sie links in ihrem für sie
ist weg du wirst ein film erstellen das
ist wirklich das verrückteste idiotische
ich jetzt was ich spielen möchte
traumfabrik von den größeren politischen
zusammenhängen nicht wissen denn es geht
ihm schon in erster linie darum eine
eine große liebesgeschichte in dieses
historische setting einzubauen
allerdings steckt eine gewisse point
natürlich drinnen dass er behauptet die
traumfabrik verdi tiefer gewesen
de facto behauptet traumfabrik aber dass
das jetzige deutsche kino die richtige
traumfabrik ist martin schreier ist ein
regisseur der sich unverhohlen an den
großen rolle gut geschichten misst
es gibt nicht wenige signale in
traumfabrik die darauf hindeuten dass er
gerne eine geschichte des ausmaßes von
titanic erzählen möchte james camerons
film dieser liebesgeschichte auf dem
unter geben schiff ist heute
wahrscheinlich die erfolgreichste
liebesgeschichte die das kino
hervorgebracht hat um nicht viel weniger
hat martin schreier offen gesprochen im
sinn
auf jeden fall sind die signale in diese
richtung eindeutig
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ganz dieses format erreichte fiel
natürlich nicht man muss allerdings
sagen dass zum beispiel die beiden
darsteller auf deutsche verhältnisse
umgewandelt durchaus format haben das
heißt das was der film von anfang an
versucht nämlich leicht zu sein dass wir
zunehmend schwieriger und deswegen ist
raum für meine begriffe ganz
interessante kompromiss bildung so dass
der film so ein bisschen in seine
bestandteile auch immer wieder zerfällt
und das ist letztendlich das gebot
sorgen dass das wichtigste eigentlich
wäre nämlich dass er seine teile auch
tatsächlich so zusammen fügt er das
eines ins andere passt und das gelingt
traumfabrik dann letztendlich doch nicht
interessant ist es aber allemal sich
diesen film anzusehen gerade wegen
seiner sehr großen ambition auch wenn er
dann würde ich doch sagen daran
scheitert aber es ist ein beleg dafür
wovon das deutsche kino im jahr 2019
träumt nämlich von der vergangenheit von
einem kino das es nicht mehr gibt und
dass es in deutschland gerade auch wegen
der deutsch-deutschen teilung aus
historischen gründen die geben konnte
und das jetzt martin schreier nachholen
noch einmal auferstehen lassen möchte
was mit ihm
dich fern von ihm
du hast ihn und nicht zufrieden an
diesem 1
du wirst deinen traum weg für ihn wird
es nicht sein